have high standards so I have a personal
story that I want to share today I've
had a friend of mine who's been helping
me with my youtube channel and she's
been giving me great advice on how to
get better and improve and make me
better on camera and it's worked you
know the channel has grown we've got
tons of great feedback as having a huge
impact on people's lives but over the
past I'd say two months she hasn't been
able to give me as much feedback and
constructive ideas as before and she
feels like she's more of a cheerleader
now and I think it's because I I'm
coming insane I want to get better it's
got to be better it's not good enough
the channel is good but it's not good
enough it's got to reach more people
it's gotta have a bigger impact and
she's saying look at how good your
channel is it's already great it's
already reaching a lot of people and yes
I agree the channel is amazing and I'm
so happy I'm so grateful for you guys
watching and I love the comments and all
of that is amazing but I still wanted to
do more I still wanted to be better and
the challenge I've discovered is we just
have different standards and her centers
are here and when I started my youtube
channel was down here and she's helped
me get better and now we're catching up
and now my channel is probably even a
little bit above her standards and so
she thinks everything is great where my
standards are up here right that's where
I want to be I want to be at Tony
Robbins level I want to be Les Brown
level I want to you know I don't want to
be those people but that's the kind of
impact that I want to have on the world
and and I'm not good enough me
personally as a speaker as a as a
YouTube creator as a someone who's
creating content I'm not good enough yet
I'm working towards it and so I have
these high standards I found the same
thing happen to my personal life as well
when I was growing up I was never a
great student I wasn't failing I was
like a B or C student and both of my
sisters were always a students and I
remember every year is where our port
cards came in I'd have to sit down with
my parents to have the talk and they
always encouraged me to do better they
never they never punished me I didn't
get grounded I didn't get you know
allowance taken away
I wasn't made to feel bad I wasn't told
you know I wasn't threatened
it wasn't very aggressive it was always
in a positive way it was always
instilling the belief in myself it was
always you know Yorkist really
Carmichael you can do this and for
whatever reason I never did you know my
standards were here and there's we're
here right and so I always you always
achieve to your standards whatever your
standards are that's what content that's
what product that's what service that's
what you're gonna create that's the life
you're gonna creep yourself because you
have limited standards I didn't
something tweaked for some reason in my
last year of high school my standards
went from here to pass see where my
parents were and I got straight 90s in
my last year of high school and I don't
know what that tweak was and my parents
were ecstatic cuz all they wanted for me
was to get A's and because my standards
exceeded theirs I outperformed their
expectations every major breakthrough
that I've had in my life and my business
has come because I've raised my
standards because I've now expected more
for myself than what I expected before
and I'd encourage you to look at your
life and your business and raise the
standards and figure out what's not good
enough anymore what are you no longer
willing to tolerate it's not acceptable
anymore
because now you've raised the standards
and look at the people who are
surrounding you look at the people in
your life do they help build you up do
they have higher standards for you than
what you have for yourself or do they
think everything is great
you know you need the cheerleaders I
guess you need the people telling you
just have some positive reinforcement
but you also need the people who give
you constructive feedback not the little
man not the haters not the people who
don't believe in you the people who
think you could be way more and people
who push you to become the best version
of yourself because if you don't have
that in your life it makes it really
hard and so that's kind of a challenge
I'm going through right now where I need
someone to push me more I'm pushing
myself as hard as I can because I'm not
satisfied with the level of what's
happening on my youtube channel right
now and that's it's all on me it's all
I'm
me being better me being better on
camera me producing better quality
content I have the team to do it I just
need to get better and I need to think
of resources and ideas and people to
help me get there so I'd encourage you
to think about what's holding you back
in your life in your business and how
changing your standards might help you
get to that next level that you're
seeking so I'd love to know from you in
what area of your life do you have
higher standards and other people who
are surrounding you I'm really curious
leave it in the comments below where do
you just have off the charts standards
where other people think it's okay
you're doing great don't worry about it
I'm really curious leave that in the
comments below I'm gonna joining the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate from the
heart everything that you guys do for me
and my channel to push me to be better
that's it continue to believe and I'll
see you soon